I do find it distressing though, that the gay community and I,
and I have gay friends who hate me even using that term now the gay community,
they really resent it, but there is a gay community. I live in West Hollywood.
I see it on the Boulevard all the time,
but I think the problem is that that is happening everywhere.
And I do think that I would love it if the gay community listened more to
someone like Morrissey,
who was constantly criticized by the gay community for just being open and
honest and saying what he feels, I don't think he's attacking anybody.
He's just,
he's not really on the right side of the political curve for most gay people.
And he's automatically attack now. That is really true for a lot of people.
I wish that was pulled back.
Your sort of view on all this is shaped by being a bad gay,
that gays are sort of outsiders off the bat.
And that does frame how you kind of look at the world a little bit.
Yeah, well look, it's what I think made me want to be a writer in many ways. Uh,
I think being gay as a kid,
then I'm not so sure now I think it's probably a lot easier and you're
a lot more, what's the word, uh,
acclimated into culture in a way at a much earlier age than we ever were.
Um, I'm a, I'm a bit older than you, but, uh,
growing up in the seventies and into the eighties, you were kind of.
Yeah. Of secret nineties, it was the same thing.
You were not out and you had to kind of navigate, uh,
these paths on your own.
One of the things that I think is really interesting about being gay is that you
have to, I think you look at the world in a much more realistic,
hard way than your straight counterpoints too.
I think that you see the world for what it's really like.
You're not really involved in the poses and in the game and ship that goes
on, uh, within, you know, societal structures.
And you also have to, you know,
redefine most everything that you experienced, culturally, whether it's movies,
whether it's pop songs, whether it's things you watch on TV,
whether it's books you read. So you really begin to,
you begin to see the world in a way that none of your other friends do,
you are an outsider. You are an outsider because of that.
But I also have to say that I did not let it define me.
And it was not something that ever got me down. I never got depressed by it.
It was something that I realized was just another thing I had to deal with among
many other things I had to deal with. It was not.
And I think this is probably where I was not that concerned with it.
And it became something that, um, was, uh, you know,
I resented the fact that I couldn't express myself in a certain way.
And I think that frustration certainly played a part in wanting to become a
writer. So I have to say, uh, you know,
um, thank you in a way. I mean, it kind of worked me definitely.
Yeah.
But when you see what sort of has happened to the gay community where it used to
maybe in the seventies and eighties and before that there was a subversive
nature to it,
a lot of good art and music and underground scenes or writing and writing and
all sorts of things came from it. Where now it seems like it's,
so the reverse it's the most sort of woke you sort of
cemented Glenn bland way of thinking. Well,
in terms of mainstream, whatever the hell that is.
That's true of everything.
And it's just that what happened last 10 years is that
gay life, whatever that means.
And I do believe that there is a certain aspect.
If you're a gay person that you do have a bit of a gay life,
it doesn't mean that it overwhelms you and everything becomes gay.
It means that, yeah, sure.
You have the same preoccupations and some of the same concerns as fellow gay
people. You obviously have to, in terms of 20 years ago, politics,
or even further back than that,
how the United States was dealing with the AIDS crisis, for example. So you,
you are, you are pushed together to a degree. Um,
but I think that that's happening all over the place.
I do find it distressing though, that the gay community and I,
and I have gay friends who hate me even using that term now the gay community,
they really resent it, but there is a gay community. I live in West Hollywood.
I see it on the Boulevard all the time.
But I think the problem is that that is happening everywhere.
And I do think that, uh,
I would love it if the gay community listed more to someone like Morrissey who
was constantly criticized by the gay community for just being open and honest
and saying what he feels, I don't think he's attacking anybody. He's just,
he's not really on the right side of the political curve for most gay people.
And he's automatically attack now. That is really true for a lot of people.
I wish that was pulled back.
And I wish that the conversation was once we're open. It just isn't right now.
And that is, that is a problem, but it's not just affecting the gay community.
It's I think everywhere.
Yeah.
Do you see that as sort of a direct offshoot of what identity politics has done?
Like if you don't identify enough as gay or the new thing is that you can be
gay. So there's like a, like a Peter teal peep, Buddha judge,
maybe the way we are a little bit version of gay,
but we're not sort of like we don't prescribe to the whole set of
ideas. It's not enough to be an out gay person living in West Hollywood,
you know, from LA for, you know, 50 years. That's that,
that doesn't quite get it.
But yeah, but you'll have to understand.
I kind of made my way through that in the eighties as a young writer.
And I knew, uh, I was in what I call the glass closet,
meaning everyone I knew, knew I was gay.
And I had a partner when I talked to the media.
I couched it back in those days. Basically,
if you came out and you were a gay writer, you were get a wise two degree,
you were, uh, put into the gay section of bookstores.
I don't think they have those anymore. I'm not sure if they did,
but they did have them. And it meant a kind of death in a way for, for,
for a mainstream acceptance.
Right. So even if you weren't writing about gay things specifically,
sort of you were gay so up, right? Look, I was on the gay channel on Sirius XM.
It was ridiculous. I didn't want to be on the gay channel.
I wanted to be on any of the politics channels. I begged them,
put me on the left channel, they'll be on the right channel, the other channel,
anything. But they were like, well, you're gay, right?
What do we do with the game?
Exactly. Which is the problem.
And that is what I always resisted because I knew I was so much more than simply
gay or were who I wanted to have sex with.
I always knew that from a very early age, that I was a writer,
that I was a person that I like movies, that I,
all these things that I wanted to do.
And then there was gay somewhere over here and I never felt the need to make
that the number one aspect of my identity.
I don't even think I even came out to anybody.
It just sort of happened gradually, Oh, you're bringing Jim to the party or, Oh,
Jim's coming for the weekend or whatever. And that was how it was.
I really didn't think that anyone kind of what I deserve a tearful coming out
from me. And I never even felt that,
that now that's not to say that people needed to go through that narrative and
that's, and that's fine, but I just didn't tie myself into,
with a gay identity. Um, and so I do think that that is a problem,
but again, not just Don, not just for gay people, but for people of color,
for women, it really had. But I also believe they,
that this is an online problem in a way there is an offline world out
there.
All that thing, that thing still exists, which are we right now?
We're I think we're having an offline conversation.
I hope I live my entire life offline to a degree, even, even when I'm online.
And I have done that.
I've gone into a lot of trouble over the past decade or so,
but I think there's an offline world and I am I'm part of it.
And I know that the way women and men and gay people express themselves are very
different than how they express themselves online.
And that is kind of where we're at right now.
And I think a lot of people are too afraid to say things that they say offline
online, and we'll just see where this plays out.
So it's funny you bring that up because I was going to mention a little bit
later, so this is jumping ahead that American psycho it's almost to me,
which was your third novel, right. It was the third novel that it's like,
we're all sort of behaving like American psycho now, you know, it'd be like,
we're all sort of sane in the functional world, in the real world. Right.
And then everyone with their secret avatars and their anonymous accounts or
whatever is a psychopath online. So maybe, maybe there's your SQL or something.
Oh, that's really interesting. I mean,
I talk a lot about the creation of American psycho in the book,
white and for some reason it's haunted me because it was something that I really
thought was going to be this strange experimental novel that maybe 3000 people
read. I thought it was so weird. So out there,
so super violent and pornographic that
never find it because it costs you some stuff we can get to that massage.
Monistic saying that I'm saying what the criticism of massaging,
just because there's acts of massage and he doesn't mean the book is massage.
And of course, so, um,
so I really didn't think that many people were going to read it,
but I also think that one of the reasons why it's still look popular
today and still in print and tons of people read the book. Um,
a lot of it has to do with the movie.
The movie definitely made people really interested in the book was because
Patrick Bateman is kind of a curator of his life in a way, uh,
very much the way people are now. I mean, a lot of, uh, American psycho.
It was almost as if Patrick Bateman is showing you a series of selfies on his
Instagram.
He's constantly describing his life and what he's wearing and what he's eating
and where he's going.
And what restaurant is that add and what dishes he's eating in the restaurant.
It basically is how people treat their lives today from this kind of like
almost God's eye view of, you know, not living or participating in it,
but actually just like photographing it.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.